thank you
good evening members and ladies and
gentlemen present
welcome to this evening's meeting of the
Southeastern area planning committee
um
I think you will know everybody except
possibly Jonathan doe maybe new to
some of you
uh Chen's notices recording of the
meeting please note that the council
will be recording and Publishing on the
council's website any part of this
meeting held in Open Session
and fire in the event of a fire officers
will notify those present please use the
fire exits marked with the green Running
Man the fire assembly point is Barclays
Bank car park please gather there and
await further instruction
and I will just pass on a message that I
think everybody's got a microphone handy
but apparently you haven't
apparently there's been problems and if
you are going to speak please make sure
you've got a the microphone and the
otherwise it's not big recorded
a gender item two apologies for absence
Hall and cancer schemes
thank you thank you
a gender item three minutes of the last
meeting to confirm the minutes of the
meeting of the committee held on the 9th
of November of this year copying closed
uh everybody I wasn't present so
is everybody else happy with what's in
it
agreed
thank you
agenda item four disclosure of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph nine and appendix B
of the code of conduct for members the
members are reminded that they also
require to disclose any such interest as
soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
while I'm speaking I will declare an
interest over homelands
partly because I wasn't present at the
last meeting and this is a continuation
of that but also because in the past
I've declared
uh an interest for this applicant as we
used to do business with a
company they had that that family had
and they owed us a considerable amount
of money
any other interests
nope
a gender item five
land adjacent to brickfield's Cottage
Green Lane Burnham on Crouch
this is the renewal of an application
that was originally approved by us in
July
2019 and Mr Dow I believe you're dealing
with it that's right chairman yes thank
you very much
this application well the history is
such that the recommendation is most
certainly approval it's at committee
because it's just outside the settlement
limit
uh the settlement limit is defined by um
mangat Chase I don't know if you can see
the person moving up and down that is
vangux Chase and the settlement limit
s the road is further to the east
um as these Stony Hills area
there's a strategic growth area in
purple there as you can see from the map
various residential development
around the site
here's a block plan of the whole site
brickfields Cottage is over to the east
although not shown on that block plan
there's two fairly recently built
um essentially completed houses to the
West
this is an extract From the Block plan
showing the proposed dwelling which is
exactly the same as previously designed
um a attached double garage to the side
there single story front Dormers
um parking and maneuvering area using
the existing access
is the front elevation
of the proposed property
as you'll see a vernacular style of
architecture cottage style
here's all four elevations
floor plans it's a three bedroom
property
um three bedrooms in the roof
foreign
this shows the existing access and the
existing access of brickfields cottage
brickfields Cottage you can just make it
out there a weapon boarded property as
is the proposed property
that's to the other side of the plot
um
the completed
um
house over to the West the garage has
just been finished off as you can see in
that slide there
and there's another house further to the
West
plans are exactly the same as was
previously approved
essentially that's it chairman thank you
very much thank you very much burner
members you wish to say at this stage
no anybody else got anything to say
agreed with the office of recommendation
's recommendation
and I'll second it I think we need some
more microphones
okay
so and that's agreed by everyone okay
great very much
move on to gender items six 13 Mill Road
tillingham
it's an outline application with all
matters reserved for two residential
units and Associated garages and again
this one is a lapsed consent that was
also approved originally well in two or
three occasions but in 2019 there's a
lot it expired and it's now come back
again before us I believe you again yes
chairman yes as you say
um give them a history the
recommendation is certainly of approval
subject to a section 106 to address the
the Rams the nature conservation as per
standard really and conditions has in
the agenda outside the settlement
boundary therefore has to come to the
committee the settlement boundary is
that line that the cursor is
going along
there's the village allotments to the
north
and an open field agricultural field to
the east
this is the block plan but it's an
indicative plan it just it has satisfied
us planners that
what is being thought for outline
planning permission could fit on the
plots they've indicated the house to the
north of there a detached garage and
um another house by the Victor access
which would be at the end of that
Hammerhead shown in the photo in between
the two existing houses
um just just shows
another view of the site
uh the house 13 Mill Lane has been
extended to the side
and has a garden a side Garden which
forms the application site shown on the
screen
and shown on the screen there really
chairman given the history the
recommendation
yes of approval thank you chairman okay
thank you uh I mean as a board member
yes I can curb everything that Mr doe
has said it's been a piece of unused
ground for as long as I can remember
since they built Mill Road I assume and
um why it wasn't completed in those days
I don't know but I'm quite happy to
agree the approval on that any other
members Council fluka yeah thank you
chairman I can remember this coming to
this community
answer
so generally if you've made a proposal I
have to support it we agree the
officer's recommendations through the
application any other members great
so you've got to prove approve it agreed
yeah okay
that's agenda item six dealt with I will
leave the room for Gen item seven and
ask the vice chairman to take over for
me
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
which is application number 2200
eight nine six four homeland's
southminster Road asheldon Miss Matthews
please thank you
occasion was deferred at the last
Saturday
for more information to be provided
providing the previous appeal with
dismissed on the site and so there's
additional information that's been
included in the officer report of course
we included some exercise in the
presentation
this application is for a four bedroom
Bungalow detached hour as a new vehicle
access
um on the inside of Shop Bend on the
Southeast Road in Asherton
this is the rotation plan showing the
application site outlined in red and the
the rest of the Homeland site at London
blue with the homelandic dwelling
existing dwelling and also shown on
there
this is a block plan showing the new
access it will be created from South
America business position here you've
got the Bungalow in this position here
and the garage and next to the Buffalo
at the end of the driveway
floor plans
showing the internal layout don't go and
garage
Ridge
through plan
Street Scene which includes the existing
Bungalow at homelands to one side and
the end view of the global Post
some photos of the site
and the gate there is showing where the
uh the position of the new axis would be
and this photo here is up and down
looking southwards for the application
site on the right hand side and then
this is a view around the bends and the
upgradation site is behind that that
bank there and you've got the assistive
Home Loans property
um in the background
until the previous appeal
this is the location plan for the
empress pillow London bed here and the
current application site is roughly
outlined in green here just to give you
some idea of the relationship between
the two so that appeals for two detached
shallow star bungalows in the in this
position these positions here
and these are the little plans and the
elevations of the
the Bunnings at work
were proposed dismissed at appeal
so the um the main points to pick out
from the previous appeal was that um the
current application would result in two
properties on on the site which was the
subject of the previous appeal inspector
commented that the two Bungalows were
quite close together it just um just
under 11 meters
um and the current application would
result in a similar relationship between
existing Homeland property and the new
Bungalow he also commented that it's on
a physically prominent
um Bend in the road and the current
application would be for Bungalow closer
to that bend than the previously
proposed running
and
um
I think there were the main points but
um to draw from the uh the appeal
decision so on that basis
um obvious feel that the application
should be refused for the the reasons as
outlined in your report and agenda thank
you
okay thank you I understand there's one
public speaker
stuff with cards if you'd like to try
and come up
[Music]
yeah yeah there's a microphone yeah I
use that microphone
[Music]
and I'm sure you haven't forgotten since
a month ago you've got two minutes here
may I ask you if everybody saw the um
updates of drawings yeah well you you
can't put a question but they have been
celebrated I can confirm that they've
been said
yeah thank you
we thank members for previously voting
to deferly supplication giving us the
opportunity to address comments from the
meeting and the reasons for refusal
there's several bus services set out in
the briefing motor councilors most
frequently is from Burn to Bradwell with
seven of daily weekdays and five on
Saturday
for Pitt costumes the inspector allowed
the appeal considering the proposal
would result in reasonably sustainable
traffic patterns and the same applies
here
self-minster is various facilities
including a convenience store Pub
swimming pool and railway station within
a short bike ride of 1.7 miles
where Private Car Travelers need
electric car charging points are within
the garage to encourage using EVS solar
panels will assist with car charging
water butts and a ground Source heat
pump will reduce dependency on Mains
water and oil deliveries
the council cannot achieve a five-year
housing land Supply government policy
provides a clear presumption in favor of
sustainable development where the Tilted
balance is engaged this is the reason
for the planning approvals and allowed
appeals listed in the briefing note
demonstrating this appeal is in a
sustainable location should be approved
there are improvements to the appearance
and setting of the proposals while
reducing Mass the roof pinch is reduced
by seven and a half degrees lowering the
reach by 635 millimeters and 1.46 meters
lower than home lens as suggested by
members and demonstrates in the street
scene
color drawings and further details on
materials are provided with the addition
of a brick length white weather boarding
and green render in keeping with the
area and providing visual interest soft
Landscaping with post and rail fencing
provides attractive boundary screening
shown in the street scene and all can be
conditioned
the footprint size and location of the
Bungalow can be compared against the
surrounding homes on the color block
plan it clearly demonstrates a mixture
and variety of plot and house sizes and
relationships this is regards that's two
minutes but bear in mind we haven't got
the clock up I'll let you continue but
just to the end of your sentence
it will not cause heart to recite a
wider area as such we respect for the
Arts members to approve this application
thank you thank you
I'd appreciate that thank you thank you
um before our third elements members
just want to come back
to stand at that stage
um there was in terms of the amended
drawings
um I did receive an email with some
memory drawing yesterday but um I have
already advised the applicant that they
received too late to be able to be
assessed and taken into account as part
of the current application and that if
they wanted revised drawings considered
at committee then they would need to
withdraw the application and resubmit
the revised drawing for consideration
and so there hasn't been time to assess
them
um or come to any view as to whether the
changes that have been Incorporated
would change office's recommendation but
on the basis that um at least two of the
reasons are on the on the basis the bids
for the development then tweaking the
design making that all the tweaks have
been referred to wouldn't change the
recommendation from a refusal to an
approval certainly
um yeah and
um
and mentioned earlier the thought that
came to mind was during that was the
there's a mention of a ground Source
heat pump but again there's no
um reference to that in the application
that is before members this evening and
in terms of where it's going to be
what's going to look like and they they
can cause some noise disturbance
sometimes so normally you've had
environmental health comments on that
that element of the proposal and before
it came to committee but
um
that was all I was going to say and
respond to the presentation thank you I
think they must serve the clarity we're
we're basically dealing with the same
application that was presented last time
to this committee yes so without any of
the Amendments that have been sent to to
members today
um before I go to the recommendation can
you can you just I think you had a you
had a that's the appeal one members I
think I find is that the that's that's
yeah and the proposed Bungalow here on
the
within the application can you show us
one that came up here
this one here
um as I said the green is the current
application site to The Bungalow
probably going in a similar position to
the garage that was proposed as part of
that appeal proposal
and then there's the two dwellings on
there yeah okay so members the the
officer's recommendation is to refuse is
that seconded
no
[Music]
or you speak for yourself but
thank you so members on them I'll hand
it over to you
well Gemini I'll put the vote if that's
what I said so those are in favor of
refusing the uh those in favor of uh
supporting the officer's recommendation
to refuse please show
it's not being second each year well I
thought it was did you not put your hand
up yeah right so if it's not being
seconded we'll we'll move on
right so members over to you
Mr chairman um
no inspectors are report on sites are
always the same they vary some may think
oh this is a good site some May so it's
not
but I'm in favor of people being able to
remain in their villages why should they
be dispersed to molding or somewhere
like that where they're cramped up in
rabbit hutches
with no real Countryside around them
so I would propose we approve this
application reference D1 and uh
and I say again that no inspectors
report are the same they vary so much
one might prove one might
discount it so I'll leave it let anyone
else add to if they want to
thank you um thank you chairman um thank
you officers
um I was a little bit bemused about the
cut the comments about the um air house
air or see the pumps the ground Source
eight pumps I should know of blooming
Engineers
um because God forbid if they are that
noisy because the amount that's going to
go in the grounds is some new
developments we're going to have a
problem with the environmental health
office so all the new developments we've
got
um I applaud them for actually wanting
to put the um green facilities in there
um I think I said at the last one I know
I've had a couple of slates chairman
that I didn't actually have a a problem
with this I took on board the officer's
recommendations
um and I still don't have a problem with
it to be fair I agree with councilor
Helm I don't think it actually is
contrary to policy D1 and S8 and H4 I
think I could be wrong chairman
um but um I actually don't have a a
problem with it and I also agree
that that the only area of concern
chairman the officer can help me is the
access to the road did highways
um recommend refusal on this application
please chair
to Chairman the current application
um
well to me that says a lot really
because I think I've had some recent
ones in my inbox for Essex County
councilor where they have actually
refused recommended refusals which is
very unusual so on that basis I don't
see that there is a a risk for safety
and there is a boss I don't know where
the bus stop is because I don't use the
buses German but I I don't have a
problem so rather than keep rambling on
I don't agree with it I agree with it
and I don't agree with the officers
thank you
um yeah I mean look this is compared to
where the inspector went with this
originally this is completely different
the the original one I know this site
well because I passed it maybe every day
but the original site was two quite
large Bungalows funding onto the road
and the inspectors are comments about
that but with this one could you show me
the rendering mismatches of how how this
Bungalow sits in relation to the
existing building
I think it might have been on your site
plan
not that one though I think you had one
that showed with the site showing the I
think the Gable end of the street view
yes sorry thank you yeah so what the
inspector didn't like last time and I
read the appeal today was the fact that
you had two Bungalows facing the road
and he didn't like it because he said
well that's not really what ashram's all
about ashram's not all about that
although it's beginning to look like
that and you've got different buildings
at different angles and it's quite a
nuclear development and I actually think
that this is a long long way away from
where the appeal decision set last time
this is a this is a more modest dwelling
facing the other way and I noticed that
the officer as part of the reason of the
refusal is sustainability and
you know I should have there was there
were lots there were several appeals one
and since then we've had lots of
applications come come through which
have come here with an officer officer's
recommendation to approve whether we
like it or not it's a sustainable
location
um you know we know there's no footpaths
we know there's no street lights but the
plan inspector is set on more than one
occasion it's sustainable so I believe
that it's sustainable and I believe that
the officers I think based on the
history of what's gone on I'm surprised
that the officers said it's not
sustainable and and you have to sort of
look at where this is because right
opposite land to the west of Saint
Anne's farmhouse
is Right opposite this and that was the
first property to be given permission on
appeal my memory serves me right and
nothing has changed since then in fact
there are there's I I remember you
questioning me last time councilman stem
and said we I wish I had that many buses
in Burnham but there's eight eight buses
a day and you'd be pleased to know that
most of them do go to Burnham so you've
got buses you've got the score
inspectors are sustainable and I
actually think that that this design and
this proposal is so different to the
proposal that was forwarded as part of
the appeal it's it's completely
different councilor Helms made a
proposal the country officers
recommendation we approve this
application I'm happy to second that
Council bill
um I just wanted to clarify a couple of
points firstly the air source heat pumps
can I just imagine that's not actually
part of okay what is then I'll crack on
with something that is which is the
highways issue and highways are
currently in with the applicant I
believe I know actually have identified
that bend for proposed words so highways
are not only aware they're actually
doing something about it well I think
there's there's a lot of history on that
then that goes back a long long way uh
how to you know deal with the problem
with all of the traffic that comes
around the bend obviously
you know that's not part of this
planning notification but I think the
critical thing as far as as this
planning application is
do not have any objections to this
um so um we have a proposal
to approve this recommended approve this
application contrary to the officer's
recommendation that's been due to
secondly by myself all those in favor of
that please show thank you
okay then well that's carried thank you
very much your plan information has been
granted so we need a reason for approval
we need conditions well the reason the
reason I can't find can you just show me
where Section 8 is in this because for
some bizarre reason it's not here
and
so well in summary chairman I think with
the Committees with the um with the
councilor Helm has proposed that he'll
need to tell us to eat his approval
no it's as the chairman it has to be the
person who proposed it has to put
forward the reason for approval well I'm
sure that I'm sure that the the
councilor Helm would have heard
everything I've said and
uh
but
it came out of my brain that is delayed
the wording that you need not just
quoting policies of what you need to
talk to the reasons for approve reasons
refusal really and obviously we would
advise you would be delegating it for
the EU to be completed for the Rams
rather than approving it as well okay
not if members approved it you could be
approving it without that would be
that's what to say this that you need to
be able to you wouldn't be approved it'd
be delegate to officers subject to the
completion of a 106. so so members can I
just to help you can I can I refer you
all and particularly counselor Helm to
page 63 of the report which deals with
the the reasons the first one uh the
councilor Mr site is located in another
Village
um basically that it's not a sustainable
location so you may wish to speak
against that now
we've got all the bus routes and
everything else going through there
so you've been stated that so you would
say then that it complies with policy
two two one two two S1 and David is that
correct that's what I thought
and uh is your iPad
valuable
very much so
and the the second reason for refusal
was to the proposed development caused
harm to the character counselor
appearances well there's so many
different houses in
I mean yeah
um
they're not one not one side there's
even the bundle on the next Corner
around
so that said that said councilor Hellman
would say that it was compliant with S8
D1 and H4 yeah
and I think we've covered the Rams well
you've been you wouldn't be approving
it'd be uh recommending approval but
delegated to office the subject
application of the yoyo I'm so so so
with with regards to the reasons why we
can we can fall away yeah that can fall
away
okay are you happy with that Mr Lee
uh no we'll leave it to you for
conditions delegate them to offices
delegated some officers and less members
have got anything there
okay so uh right so the good news is uh
as I said earlier uh it's been improved
and now you actually know why
please thanks
[Music]
thank you
I think he gets the fluka for that
um
agenda item eight any other items of
business the chairman committee decides
are Urgent I have none as such except to
uh for those of you don't know that you
know that Mr Lee will be leaving us and
this may well be his last meeting
tonight
it's present for you members yeah
he's moving on to past she's new I'm
disclosed as yet okay
I think everyone enjoyed me
and regardless of what you think we've
learned a lot we've been very grateful
for your guidance
I think he survived this committee he
can survive most things
thank you
and apart from that this is obviously
the last um
meeting of this calendar year and uh
for this committee and Christmas is
around the corner so I'll wish you all a
Merry Christmas and thank you all for
your help and throughout the year and we
will
no doubt to see each other before
Christmas but if not we'll see you all
in January
and there's no urgent business no I did
deal with it
but it is failure
and uh I will close the meeting at three
minutes past eight